I can't express how disabling ADHD is
my brain literally does not work right
I have been so like
depressed and rotting for weeks
my apartment has been a mess
I've just been feeling like so shitty
first I had a friend visiting so I had to like clean the depression nest
and I took a Vyvanse today so that I can clean
not only is my apartment clean
but I'm also doing like that
my bags my ADHD bag
like my several bags
like have things thrown in them for a different time to deal with
and you don't remember what's in there
cause like if you don't see
it doesn't exist
so then you just have like
several bags of things
I'm dealing with my ADHD bags just because
and it's just a sharp reminder that like
if my brain worked
I wouldn't be the way that I am
like I'm not just an inherently lazy person
like there is something wrong with me
and a little fucking pill can fix it
but I haven't been able to get my medication for 2 months
over 2 months
because of the vyvanse shortage
so I'm just using the pills like
when I need them
but I just can't imagine what my life would be like
if I could just operate like this all the time